le départ de l'armée française du mali
véritable casse tête logistique aux
implications multiples il faudra d'abord
vider les trois bases installées dans le
pays gao gossip et ménaka soit 2400
soldats français de l'opération barkan
qui participe depuis 2014 à la traque
des groupes jihadistes dans le sahel il
ne devrait a priori pas rejoindre les
2400 autres militaires stationnés dans
les pays voisins le golfe de guinée
autre front de la lutte anti terroriste
pourrait être un point de chute
potentiels au delà de barkan le retrait
français qui s'étalera sur une période
de six mois à un an va également
entraîner la fin de la force takouba
créé il ya moins de deux ans
cette task force regroupe 800 membres
des forces spéciales dont une moitié de
français très autres pays européens y
ont participé la suède s'est retiré en
janvier dernier suivie du danemark dont
la junte malienne a exigé le départ
autre conséquence de la décision de
paris l'évacuation des contingents
européens de la minus ma soit environ
10% des forces de cette mission des
nations unies au mali ainsi que celle
des dizaines de membres de l'utm la
mission de formation de l'union
européenne au mali malgré le retrait de
toutes ses troupes la france va
provisoirement continuer d'apporter un
soutien aérien et médical à la minus
mahéo forces armées maliennes enfin les
unités des forces spéciales sabres basé
au burkina faso seront toujours
susceptible d'intervenir de manière
ciblée du côté malien de la frontière